interview le pire est à venir
thierry lhermitte est ce que vous
soupçonnez mentir oui bien sûr moi ça
tombe bien je dis toujours à l'héritage
qu'on va faire l'interview manche en la
bouche pendant les guînes galles dès
qu'il ya pas d'afficher un bonheur cette
émission les débats fist au mexique
c'est insensé j'ai reçu un email et au
mexique n'ont pas lui il ya des daf
histo mais revendique des gens qui
regardent l'émission au mexique il bouge
pendant le jingle et qui ça sent cesti
soit alors à l'époque de deux pasteurs
je vis des relations homosexuelles et
que gérard jugnot
bah oui enfin mais c'est vrai que
récemment c'est vrai que récemment vous
avez décidé de faire un petit essai tous
les deux à nouveau ensemble
il veut pas à la mais voilà le problème
c'est qu'on veut paraît voilà c'est vrai
je pense qu'il faut rien n'est perdu
je te le dit gérard voit la caméra je te
le digère je suis encore là et je crois
je t'attendrai toute ma vie bien t'y
retail en continu vous avez fait votre
service militaire dans légion étrangère
vous avez eu une aventure avec un
sergent un ancien de l'indo qui était le
fils naturel du général de bull
ça ne s'est pas beaucoup non
effectivement c'est qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment
alors mais quand on sait lire entre les
lignes des articles de fond et on le
comprend effectivement il était beau non
il sentait bon le sable chaud
alors au début du sport didier gigolo
pour pour payer les travaux
vous en avez souffert de ça ça vous avez
humilié nom et que je ne crache pas non
monsieur
j'ai déjà le reste des vrais géants du
gérant dur croyez moi vous êtes un film
porno le problème premier film en fait
c'est un film porno avec brigitte lahaie
vous avez une aventure de plusieurs mois
avec elle et elle elle dit vous quand
elle parle de vous elle dit il aurait pu
être un super rocco siffredi là je peux
pas répondre à cette question vous avez
déchets j'avais déchaîné les foules
là je ne peux même pas non merci
brigitte à votre boîte échangiste
préféré à paris en ce moment c'est quoi
c'est je suis pas tout à chebba jo lawry
thérèse à dakar il connaît alors hélène
elle prend comment votre aventure avec
claire keim là pendant le tournage du
film le roman de lulu
voilà une habitude énorme
oui c'est bien c'est pas méchant fait
quand même temps vous êtes ensemble
cette femme est chargé 25 tués we will
ses habitués bien sûr j'ai pas de
problème non au nom de nord éclair elle
supporte que vous aviez quand même de
temps encore la maison elle si c'est
plus dur pour elle le dimanche à midi
jpeg est obligé d'aller j'avais envie
d'aller voir les enfants et tout comme
ça juste plus humain j surg thierry tu
ailles vous êtes un grand ami de jean
marie le pen
vous n'êtes pas désolé un petit peu par
la disparition du front national du
paysage politique français sont ils se
sont gâchées vraiment rêver
ils ont déconné évidemment quand on a
des cantons et des beaux amis comme ça
c'est se brouiller pour une histoire de
cul c'est tombé avec sa muse dont vous
êtes le plus riche en fait des anciens
du splendid vous investissez beaucoup
dans les airs aux senteurs dans le nord
de l'europe et vous avez une spécialité
c'est la russe fait venir des des
camions de russan fait des légers russe
des slovènes
ça marche bien est spécialisée dans pays
de l'est ce goût j'avais des amis qui
bêtement on a mis en yougoslavie qui
vient de se faire incarcérer mais très
bêtement mais ils pourront fournissait
c'était sympa mais qu'est ce qu'elles
ont le plus les filles de l'est pourquoi
voulez vous pouvez obtenir par camion
par wagons entiers sont sincères à
cesson bien sûr elle compte pas alors
déclaré je voudrais mourir comme elvis
presley bourré de tranquillisants bourré
de sucre est en train de sauter des
lolitas vous maintenez ça oui c'est une
sorte d'apothéose devant votre classe
vous essayer de chanter comme elvis et
tout ça donc je sais que pour moi est
vraiment les russes et les lolitas
photo c claire keim patrick bouchitey
neymar comme chez vous